From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio International. Public Radio. Public-- Radio International. Radio International. One more time.
来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。公共广播。公共——国际广播电台。国际广播电台。再来一次。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
A few years ago, I was putting together a story about a high school senior prom. And after the prom, I tagged along with two couples in a Ford Tempo, as they drove around, going to parties, talking, and joking, and singing along with the radio. We drove to pick up a friend of theirs at her house, but all the lights at her house were off, and nobody seemed at home.
几年前，我正在制作一个关于高中毕业舞会的故事。舞会结束后，我跟着两对情侣坐进一辆福特Tempo汽车，他们开车四处转悠，去参加派对，聊天、开玩笑，跟着收音机唱歌。我们开车去她家接一个朋友，但她家所有的灯都关着，似乎没人在家。
Wait, this isn't her house. This isn't her house.
等等，这不是她家。这不是她家。
Yes, it is. Her car's right there.
没错，就是这儿。她的车就在那儿。
Really? I don't remember this being her house. Is it?
真的吗？我不记得这是她家。是吗？
You guys have been friends for such a long time, you don't even know where her house is, man.
伙计，你们都当了这么久的朋友了，竟然连她家在哪都不知道。
Hey, hey, this is her new house, all right?
嘿，嘿，这是她的新家，好吗？
All right?
好吧？
A word now about doing documentary stories. When you're doing this kind of story, this is pretty much exactly the kind of moment that you dream of. Everybody's acting the way they act when there's no tape recorder present. It's intimate. It's alive.
现在说点关于做纪录片报道的事。当你做这种报道时，这基本上就是你梦寐以求的时刻。每个人表现得就像没有录音机在场一样。它是亲密的。它是鲜活的。
You feel like you're hearing these people as they really are even though there is a tape recorder and a boom microphone, a huge one, a foot and a half long, and a stranger. And to get to this point, you have to spend hours with people, get them used to you, get them to the point where they're actually bored with being recorded. And I tell you all this really only as a prelude to telling you this story.
你会觉得你听到了这些人最真实的一面，尽管现场有录音机，还有一个吊杆麦克风——一个又大又长，有一英尺半长——还有一个陌生人。为了达到这种状态，你必须花几个小时和人们待在一起，让他们习惯你的存在，让他们达到对被录音感到厌烦的地步。我告诉你这一切，其实只是为了引出这个故事。
A while back, a guy named Joe Silovsky bought some old reel-to-reel tapes at a Salvation Army thrift store. And he took them home. And one of those tapes had exactly this quality tape on it, like in a really good documentary, that is, the people spoke the way that they really talk in real life. It was intimate. And it completely revealed what the people speaking were like.
不久前，一个叫乔·西洛夫斯基的人在救世军旧货店买了一些旧的盘式录音带。他把它们带回了家。其中一盘录音带里恰好有这种高质量的内容，就像非常好的纪录片一样，也就是说，人们说的是他们在现实生活中真正的说话方式。它是私密的。而且它完全揭示了说话的人是什么样子的。
And hearing that tape gave us the idea for today's program, that we're going to devote the whole show to three stories made out of found tape like this. Accidental Documentaries, we call them.
听了那盘录音带给了我们今天节目的灵感，我们将用整期节目来讲述三个由这种现成的录音带制作的故事。我们称它们为“意外的纪录片”。
Act One takes place 30 years ago in Michigan. Act Two happens 40 years ago in my hometown, Baltimore. And Act Three happens 25 years ago here in Chicago. Stay with us.
第一幕发生在30年前的密歇根州。第二幕发生在40年前我的家乡巴尔的摩。第三幕发生在25年前的芝加哥。请继续收听。
Act One, Berrien Springs, Michigan. The tape that Joe Silovsky found is from 1967. It came in one of those boxes. I don't know if you remember these boxes that reel-to-reel tape came in in the '60s, and '70s, and '80s. And it fits two hours of tape. It's not that big. It's nine-inch reel of tape, two hours of tape.
第一幕，密歇根州贝里安斯普林斯。乔·西洛夫斯基发现的录音带是1967年的。它是装在那种盒子里面的。我不知道你是否还记得60、70和80年代盘式录音带装的那种盒子。它能装两小时的录音带。没那么大。那是九英寸的录音带盘，两小时的录音。
And the box had stamps all over it, and addresses written, and crossed out, and written. And what it was was a letter on tape between this family in Michigan, the Davis family, and their son, Arthur, Junior, who was in medical school in Loma Linda, California. And the tape is interesting because it documents pretty thoroughly life in this one American family.
盒子上贴满了邮票，写着地址，有划掉的，也有重写的。那其实是一封录在磁带里的信，寄件人是密歇根州的戴维斯一家，收件人是他们正在加州洛马琳达医学院读书的儿子阿瑟二世。这盘录音带很有趣，因为它非常详尽地记录了一个美国家庭的生活。
Hello, son. There isn't much news. Grace was over one day. And she was feeling so bad about her marital situation. So I gave her this reality therapy book.
你好，儿子。没什么新闻。格蕾丝有一天过来过。她对自己的婚姻状况感到非常难过。所以我给了她这本现实疗法书。
And by the way, I sent you one, son. You'll be getting it in the mail soon. I had it sent right direct to you. It isn't that I think you need it. It's just a new insight on mental health, mental illness, that I think is good.
顺便说一句，儿子，我也给你寄了一本。你很快就会在邮件里收到。并不是我觉得你需要它。这只是对心理健康、心理疾病的一种新见解，我觉得挺好的。
I probably told you about the chapter I read to Jimmy when we were riding to Mrs. Lester's voice lesson. And it was a chapter on nagging. Smart wives don't have to nag. And it was so interesting. Halfway through it, I realized that this was written for me because I do nag quite a bit. And here, it brought out that sometimes a person nags because they want to feel superior.
我可能跟你说过我读给吉米听的那一章，当时我们正要去莱斯特夫人的声乐课。那是关于唠叨的一章。聪明的妻子不需要唠叨。那真的很引人深思。读到一半时，我意识到这是写给我的，因为我确实唠叨得不少。书里指出，有时人唠叨是因为他们想感到优越。
Each time they-- well, here, I'll read it, son. "If you stop to think about it, you know perfectly well that this sort of nagging, that means nagging to get things done and things, isn't correcting the evil of what you complain. It's only making you feel important, virtuous, and superior. So for goodness sake, find some more constructive way of enhancing your feeling of virtue if it's so badly in need of being enhanced."
每次他们——好吧，在这里，我读给你听，儿子。“如果你停下来想一想，你心里很清楚，这种唠叨，也就是为了让事情做成而进行的唠叨，并不能纠正你所抱怨的事情的恶果。它只是让你感到自己很重要、很正直、很优越。所以，看在上帝的份上，如果你的优越感这么需要提升，去找点更具建设性的方式吧。”
Daddy has been very, very busy working in the basement. One of the machines is broken down. And true to form, it's taken him a long, long time to fix it. We're behind as usual on strips. Jack goofed, I guess, in his order of extrusions. And we are out of extrusions and won't be having them until Friday.
爸爸一直在地下室忙着工作。其中一台机器坏了。不出所料，他花了很长很长时间才修好。我们像往常一样在加工条材上落后了。杰克订购挤压件时搞砸了，我想。我们没有挤压件了，要到周五才能有。
I made $50 in one week and a half. That's when I bought-- I bought your suit, and paid my tithe, and things like this. Well, son, I'll say goodbye. But thank you for your words of advice as far as my resting. And thank you for being concerned about my welfare.
我在一个半星期里赚了50美元。那时我买了——我买了你的西装，交了十一奉献，还有诸如此类的事情。好吧，儿子，我要说再见了。谢谢你关于我休息的建议。也谢谢你关心我的健康。
I really have gotten along quite well recently. I didn't feel too bad of depression last month. Well, here I go. We'll see you again. And I'll let someone else talk on the tape. Bye-bye.
我最近确实过得还不错。上个月我没觉得有多抑郁。好吧，我要挂了。我们会再见面的。我让别人在磁带里说几句。再见。
Hello, Joe. How do you like this big tape anyhow? Isn't this pretty neat? I don't know if we ever get the thing filled up. And if we do get it filled up, I don't know whether you'll ever have the time to listen to it or not.
你好，乔。你觉得这盘大磁带怎么样？这不是很整洁吗？我不知道我们能不能把它录满。即使录满了，我也不知道你是否有时间听它。
Things are surely busy around here. They're really popping. I didn't get to bed 'til after 1 o'clock though. I was working downstairs, and I had work ready to take up to Jack's today, so we can get paid. We don't have any strips right now though. I guess I got a call for supper, so I'll come back later.
这儿真是忙得不可开交。事情进展得非常快。不过我一直到1点多才睡觉。我在楼下工作，今天还要把成品带去杰克那里，这样我们就能拿到钱了。不过我们现在没有条材了。我想我听到叫我吃晚饭的声音了，我待会儿再回来。
I heard a little story that I thought I would tell you, Joe. Mom reminded me at the supper table. I just got back from eating supper. There were a couple out. They were getting acquainted, shall we say, doing a little French kissing. And the fella said, "Oh, I think I got your gum." And she said, "No." She said, "I got a bad cold." So I'll leave you with that little thought for the time being.
我听到一个小故事，我想讲给你听，乔。妈妈在晚饭桌上提醒了我。我刚吃完晚饭回来。有一对情侣出去了。我们可以说他们正在互相了解，做一点法式接吻。然后那个男的说：“噢，我想我吃到你的口香糖了。”她说：“不，我有重感冒。”所以，暂时就把这个小段子留给你吧。
Hi, Joe. I just got through talking to you on the phone. Little Kenny [? Jacques, ?] who I don't know if you remember him or not, but he's Quint [? Jacques's ?] oldest son, got married last March. And his girlfriend was here in school. And they were intending to keep it quiet until after school was out, but I guess he's pregnant now. So I suppose when you fool around, and do things like that, why, I suppose that's the price you're prepared to take. But I guess he's still in the Army.
嗨，乔。我刚跟你通过电话。小肯尼——我不知道你还记不记得他，他是昆特的大儿子——去年三月结婚了。他女朋友当时在这儿上学。他们打算等毕业后再公开，但我猜她现在怀孕了。所以我猜当你胡闹，做那种事情时，你就要准备好承担代价。不过我猜他还在军队里。
I saw him tonight in the drive-in. They look real happy together. She seems like a real nice little girl, almost too nice for him. He's a real nice fella, but he's quite mentally retarded, I think. At least, he may not be mentally retarded, but he has an awful time in school trying to figure out his ABC's. Anyway, that's the way it goes.
我今晚在汽车影院看到他了。他们看起来很幸福。她看起来是个非常好的小姑娘，对他来说太好了。他是个很好的人，但我认为他有点智力迟钝。至少，他可能不是智力迟钝，但他学拼音字母时费了很大的劲。不管怎样，事情就是这样。
And she seems to be real happy with him. She went with Carl Hamel before. And she seems like a good Christian girl. She's got one hand that's deformed. I suppose that makes her feel like it'd be awfully for her to get anybody. So she probably thought she'd take whatever she could get.
她看起来和他在一起真的很幸福。她以前和卡尔·哈梅尔在一起过。她看起来是个虔诚的好女孩。她有一只手是畸形的。我猜这让她觉得很难找到另一半。所以她可能想，能找个什么样的就找什么样的吧。
It was interesting as we visited Aunt Menta and Uncle Wendall's this weekend. We just had a real nice time. But I felt a little odd about going and suggested in a very small way that Art ought to call Menta. But sometimes he gets real negative about my suggestions. And I realized that it's because many times I perhaps force myself on him. So I didn't say anything until about 50 miles before we got there.
这周末去门塔阿姨和温德尔叔叔家做客挺有趣的。我们玩得很开心。但我对去那儿感到有点奇怪，并委婉地建议阿瑟应该给门塔打个电话。但他有时会对我的建议表现得非常消极。我意识到这是因为很多时候我可能强迫他接受我的想法。所以我一直到离那儿只有50英里时才开口。
I really felt as though Menta should know we were coming. I should have written and told her. But I've left the communication with his family to Daddy. Well, he got a little bit vexed, and jumped out of the car, and went to the telephone, saying, "I hope you're satisfied now." But when he came back, Menta hadn't realized we were coming. And we were all grateful that we'd made the telephone call even though I didn't want to be right and say, "I told you so." Because it wouldn't have been nice to have walked in on them at a quarter to 10:00 at night.
我真的觉得门塔应该知道我们要去。我本该写信告诉她的。但我一直把和阿瑟家人的沟通交给爸爸。好吧，他有点恼火，跳下车去打电话，说：“希望你现在满意了。”但他回来时，门塔根本不知道我们要去。我们都很庆幸打了那个电话，尽管我并不想为了证明自己是对的而说“我早跟你说了”。因为如果在晚上9点45分不请自来，那太不礼貌了。
It was interesting how genuinely they accepted us. I don't know if I could be that gracious or not. Although they live such different lives. They had no plans for the weekend. We came. This was fine. And we ate what they had. And this was it.
有趣的是他们多么真诚地接纳了我们。我不知道自己是否能有那么大度。虽然他们的生活方式如此不同。他们周末没有计划。我们来了。这就很好。我们吃了他们家里有的东西。就是这样。
But I think of if the situation were reversed and Ment and Wendall dropped in on us, how many times we have company over the weekend, we have to go to functions, and we have music lessons, and things like this, and our lives are so completely different. It's interesting that we just spent all day sitting without doing anything at all. And this is so unusual for us. And even though I don't suppose I could do it every week, it did seem good for one week, just to sit, and look at each other, and talk. Ment and Wendall are sweet people really. It's very difficult for me not to judge a person's Christian experience.
但我想，如果情况反过来，门塔和温德尔突然造访我们家呢？我们周末有多少次有客人，我们要参加活动，我们要上音乐课之类的，我们的生活完全不同。有趣的是，我们整天坐着什么也没做。这在我们看来太不寻常了。虽然我不认为我可以每周都这样做，但坐着，看着对方，聊天，这似乎对这一周很好。门塔和温德尔真是可爱的人。我很难不去评判一个人的基督徒经历。
Darlene was voicing her experience last night. Art was a little bit perturbed because her skirt was too short. And Darlene was telling me that, really, she, in a way, resented Daddy's religion because it seemed to be so void of actual feeling and love. And I felt rather bad this morning. I got up to have my worship. I neglected it over the weekend.
达琳昨晚正在表达她的心声。阿瑟有点不安，因为她的裙子太短了。达琳告诉我，在某种程度上，她真的很怨恨爸爸的宗教，因为它似乎太缺乏真实的情感和爱了。我今天早上感觉相当糟糕。我起床做礼拜。周末我忽略了它。
And I got up to have my worship. And as I did, Daddy came in and sat down beside me. And I felt rather funny because I really feel that he does this as a duty more than anything else. And when I have my worship, I feel communication with God, and I enjoy what I'm reading. And when Daddy came in, there was just a-- I don't know. I suppose you'd call it an inner resentment.
我起床做礼拜。当我这样做的时候，爸爸走了进来，坐在我旁边。我感觉有点怪，因为我真的觉得他做这个更多是出于职责。而当我做礼拜时，我感到与上帝的交流，我很享受我读的内容。当爸爸进来时，只是有一种——我不知道。我想你会称之为内心的抵触。
I didn't know quite what to do. I was right in the middle of reading a chapter. So for the first time in my life, rather than to try to anticipate what he wanted and his needs, I just let him sit there. And I thought if he would say to me, "Could I have worship with you?" it would be fine. But he didn't. So I just continued reading and didn't say anything at all. He sat there for a little while, and then he left.
我不知道该怎么办。我正读到书的中间。所以这是我一生中第一次，与其试图去揣测他想要什么和他的需要，我只是让他坐在那里。我想如果他对我说：“我可以和你一起做礼拜吗？”那会很好。但他没有。所以我只是继续读，什么也没说。他坐了一会儿，然后就离开了。
Hi, Joe. That was sure nice to hear from you the other night. What I wanted to talk to you about tonight was I wanted to tell you about our power feed. This power feed that I made, we got that going now. So I got a hydraulic cylinder from Bimba, put that on there, and put some microswitches on there. And as the thing goes up, it pulls the chain around the sprocket.
嗨，乔。前几天听到你的消息真是太好了。今晚我想跟你谈谈我们的动力进给装置。这个我做的动力进给装置，我们现在已经开始用了。我从Bimba买了一个液压缸，把它装上去，然后装了一些微动开关。当东西上升时，它会拉动链条绕过链轮。
I think that if Daddy feels a spiritual lack and feels a need, then he, himself, ought to be the aggressive one and fulfill this need in his own way.
我想，如果爸爸感到精神上的缺失和需要，那么他自己应该主动去以自己的方式满足这种需要。
So put that sprocket on there. And as the cylinder goes in, it pulls the chain that goes around the sprocket, it pulls it up and pushes the drill down.
所以把那个链轮装上去。当油缸缩回时，它会拉动绕在链轮上的链条，把它向上拉，把钻头向下压。
I would love to begin to have worship with Daddy, together, as husband and wife.
我多么希望能开始和爸爸一起做礼拜，作为夫妻一起。
And then when it gets to the other microswitch, why, it comes back. And as it comes back, we've got weights on the other side of the sprocket, pulling the chain in the other direction.
然后当它到达另一个微动开关时，它就回来了。当它回来时，我们在链轮的另一边装了砝码，向相反方向拉动链条。
We certainly have begun to enjoy many relationships that are very, very fulfilling in our marriage. But as far as this worship is concerned, it seems as though I'm always the one that has to make the initiative, plunge and say, "Well, come, have worship with me," and select things that are inspiring. And I think this is wrong.
我们当然已经开始享受我们婚姻中许多非常有意义的关系了。但就这个礼拜而言，似乎总是要我主动，去推动，去说：“好吧，来，和我一起做礼拜吧，”并选择一些有启发性的内容。我觉得这是不对的。
And this new compressor works like a dream. It really is doing a good job for us, which makes us very happy. We're real happy with the results we're getting so far.
这个新压缩机效果好极了。它确实为我们做了很好的工作，这让我们非常高兴。我们对目前得到的结果非常满意。
I was reading an article last week, where we, so many times, try to fit people into our own pattern rather than to understand their background and appreciate their own pattern. And I think that he ought to fulfill his spiritual needs in his own way.
上周我读了一篇文章，说我们很多时候试图让人们适应我们自己的模式，而不是去理解他们的背景并欣赏他们自己的模式。我觉得他应该以他自己的方式来满足他的精神需求。
Ken is going to come over. Ken Scholski. I don't know whether you know him or not. But he does real good at drilling the big holes. So he's going to come over and drill a couple hundred of the strips with the big holes for us. So we can at least get into production again by tomorrow night.
肯要过来了。肯·斯科尔斯基。我不知道你认不认识他。但他钻大孔很在行。所以他要过来帮我们钻几百个带大孔的条材。这样我们至少到明天晚上就能重新开始生产了。
Because I don't really know the depths of his spirituality and his basic needs.
因为我真的不知道他精神世界的深度和他基本的需求。
This one is practically foolproof, as long as we don't put too much air pressure on it and drive it too hard.
这个简直是万无一失的，只要我们不加太大的气压，不让它运行得太猛。
So because I have no way of knowing, I'm going to stop worrying.
所以因为我无从得知，我决定不再担心了。
We've been drilling some extrusions, 18-inch extrusions on the press with two holes at a time. It's been going pretty good.
我们一直在压机上钻挤压件，18英寸的挤压件，一次钻两个孔。进展相当顺利。
Daddy's calling, so bye-bye, son. And I'll see you later. I just had to tell you, son. Daddy screamed and hollered. You may have heard him over the tape, "Honey!" And I was right in the middle of a sentence to you, so I didn't go.
爸爸在叫我了，所以再见，儿子。回头见。我不得不告诉你，儿子。爸爸尖叫大喊。你可能在磁带里听到了他喊，“亲爱的！”我当时正在跟你说话说到一半，所以我没过去。
But when I ran down, here, he has this power feed on. You know Daddy. He is very, very slow at what he does. And everyone has about lost their temper at him because they've tried so hard to be patient. And day by day, they've hoped this thing gets fixed.
但我跑下去一看，他把这个动力进给装置装好了。你知道爸爸。他做事情非常非常慢。每个人都快被他磨光了耐心，因为他们已经尽力去宽容他了。他们日复一日地希望这东西能修好。
And so now I find this morning that he had fixed it. And this John that is working there was sitting there and working this just as easy as could be. And of course, everyone was really thrilled. And Daddy was so tickled. He was just as tickled as a little boy really.
所以今天早上我发现他修好了。那个在那里工作的约翰正坐在那儿，操作起来简直轻松极了。当然，每个人都非常兴奋。爸爸也很高兴。他真的像个小男孩一样高兴。
So son, we love you. We'll see you. I want to save some room here for your lady love. Good night.
所以儿子，我们爱你。再见。我想在这里给你的爱人留点位置。晚安。
Well, son. I don't know who's talked.
好吧，儿子。我不知道谁说了话。
So son, we love you. We'll see you. I want to save some room here for your lady love. Good night.
所以儿子，我们爱你。再见。我想在这里给你的爱人留点位置。晚安。
If I had the money, I would have called you tonight. It's funny. When you have an emotional problem, you don't quite know where to turn. They can say, "Turn to the Lord." And I think this is true. And yet, we're so human. We want human help.
如果有钱，我今晚就会给你打电话。真滑稽。当你遇到情绪问题时，你不知道该向谁求助。他们会说，“转向主。”我想这是对的。然而，我们终究是人。我们想要人的帮助。
I just come back from taking a walk this evening, thinking, "If I could just talk with someone." And of course, you don't talk your problems out with too many people. And so I decided I'd turn the tape recorder on. And you could hear a negative [CLEARS HER THROAT]-- I'm trying to get a cold-- you could hear the negative side of the Davis household, which has been typical in the last few years.
我刚从今晚的散步中回来，心想，“如果我能和某人谈谈就好了。”当然，你不会和太多人谈论你的问题。所以我决定打开录音机。你可以听到戴维斯一家的消极面——（清嗓子）——我在感冒——你可以听到戴维斯一家的消极面，这在过去几年里是很典型的。
Here's Darlene. I could go on and on, and I know I must stop. Bye-bye, son.
达琳在这儿。我可以没完没了地说下去，但我知道我必须停下来。再见，儿子。
Hi, Art. This week has really been a week, I tell you. I think it was Monday afternoon, I went into Mrs. Hare's office. And she told me that I would not be able to take my test because of my debit, which is $500-and-some. And that was very upsetting to me of course. I didn't realize I couldn't take my test for this.
嗨，阿瑟。我跟你说，这周真是糟糕透了。我想是周一下午，我去了海尔夫人的办公室。她告诉我，因为我的债务——500多美元——我不能参加考试。那当然让我非常难过。我没想到会因为这个不能考试。
There's no excuse for this really other than that I can see for the first time she has money of her own. And it's the little things that she's bought. It seems good to just have money and spend it. And at the first of the year, she really probably didn't work quite as much as she should've. Regardless of what's gone over the dam, she's left with a $500 bill now. And well, naturally, we brought the problem to Daddy.
这真的没什么借口，除了我第一次看到她有自己的钱了。那是她买的一些小东西。手里有钱花感觉真好。在年初，她可能确实没有像她应该做的那样工作。不管过去发生了什么，她现在剩下了一张500美元的账单。好吧，自然，我们把问题带给了爸爸。
First, I talked with Dad about it. And he said he'd see what he could do. Well, he didn't do anything. There just seems to be no understanding at all there. But I guess that's to be expected, being what Daddy's like.
首先，我和爸爸谈了这件事。他说他会看看能做什么。好吧，他什么也没做。那里似乎根本没有任何理解。但我想这是意料之中的，毕竟爸爸就是那样的人。
When Darlene found this out from Mrs. Hare, she came home and cried an hour while I was teaching music lessons. And after the lessons, I went up and found out what the problem was. Naturally, she realizes her mistake. She's defeated. She doesn't know which way to turn. And I explained this to Art last night that she had realized that she made mistakes.
当达琳从海尔夫人那里知道这件事时，她回家哭了一个小时，当时我正在教音乐课。课后，我上去了解了情况。自然，她意识到了自己的错误。她被击败了。她不知道该往哪儿走。我昨晚向阿瑟解释说，她已经意识到她犯了错误。
But goodness knows how many mistakes we've made in life. And as parents, if we could just help her pick up the pieces and somehow put them together again, so she wouldn't feel defeated, this would be so much more rewarding. But I also told him that I felt that we hadn't really helped you children too much with your schooling and that it seemed to me, and I'm sure you children felt the same way, that there were hundreds of dollars that goes into the basement. And I didn't really think it was right. Well, this he resented very much.
但上帝知道我们在生活中犯过多少错误。作为父母，如果我们能帮她收拾残局，设法把它们重新拼凑起来，这样她就不会感到挫败，那会更有意义。但我同时也告诉他，我觉得我们并没有真正帮你们这些孩子太多学校里的事，而且在我看来——我相信你们这些孩子也觉得一样——有几百美元投进了地下室。我觉得这真的不太对。好吧，这让他感到非常不满。
Mom said she thought I ought to help her on this bill. But I don't know whether I'm wrong in this situation or not, but I feel in a way that she had this coming because she hasn't put in her full time. This last month she has. But up until that time, she's agreed for 12 hours a week, and it's been usually around-- oh, I imagine 5 to 6 hours is a lot closer to what's actually been accomplished. And then the money she does get, she's been spending on so many incidentals. And I kept talking and talking, but it didn't seem to do much good.
妈妈说她认为我应该帮她付这笔账单。但我不知道在这种情况下我是否错了，但在某种程度上，我觉得这是她自找的，因为她没有全时工作。这个月她工作了。但在那之前，她同意每周工作12小时，通常只有——噢，我想5到6小时更接近实际完成的工作量。而且她挣到的钱，都花在了很多零碎开销上。我一直说个不停，但似乎没什么用。
But I feel it's better to provide a way for children to earn their education than it is to actually give them the money. And besides, we don't have the money. And if we weren't working down in the basement, why, there wouldn't be any money any more than there is right now. In fact, there wouldn't be as much. So I don't know.
但我认为，为孩子们提供赚取教育费用的途径，比直接给他们钱要好。再说，我们也没有那笔钱。如果我们不在地下室工作，那么就不会再有钱了。事实上，钱会比现在少。所以我不知道。
I guess I get mixed up in my philosophy and my thinking sometimes. And I know Darlene sometimes resents the fact that we don't give her more money. She sees all these other folks getting money, and she doesn't. I don't know exactly what to do about the situation. I don't know what's really right and what's wrong.
我想我的哲学和思考有时会混在一起。我知道达琳有时会因为我们没给她更多的钱而感到不满。她看到其他人都拿到钱了，而她没有。我不知道该如何处理这种情况。我不知道什么是真正对的，什么是错的。
But right now, I'm pretty strapped with all the taxes. I just had to pay $400 out at the first of the month. And now I come here again in the middle of the month and have to pay another $200.
但现在，各种税费让我压力很大。月初我刚交了400美元。现在又是月中，我又得再交200美元。
Just a minute. Back again. Dad just came up to talk to me for a few minutes. I didn't know if I was going to work for him this summer or not after our little mix-up here. But I guess I'm going to work at the school and then in the afternoons for Dad because I have to pay off this debt just as soon as I can.
稍等一下。我回来了。爸爸刚上来跟我谈了几分钟。在发生这起小冲突后，我不知道这个夏天我是否还会为他工作。但我猜我会先在学校工作，下午再去帮爸爸，因为我必须尽快还清这笔债。
Well, anyway, be that as it may, Rich told a story he was told about a little mama mouse that lived on the-- oh, there goes-- the thing is running downstairs now. I can hear it clicking-- told about a little girl mouse that lived on one side of the corn field. And the little boy mouse lived on the other side of the field. And one day, the little girl mouse in the autumn made a trip across the field. And when she got to the little boy's house, she said, "Help, help, I've been reaped. I've been reaped." They were reaping the corn.
好吧，不管怎样，里奇讲了一个故事，他说的是关于一只住在——噢，那儿——东西在楼下运行了。我可以听到它在点击——讲的是一只住在玉米田一边的老鼠妈妈。小老鼠住在田的另一边。有一天，小老鼠在秋天穿过田野。当她到达小老鼠家时，她说：“救命，救命，我被收割了。我被收割了。”他们当时在收割玉米。
And old Darlene just laughed and laughed. But she couldn't figure out what she was laughing at. The more she talked, the worse it got. She couldn't get the connection to the whole thing. See, she said, she thought it had something to do with emptying garbage or something. I don't remember just what her statement was. Anyway, it really made it quite funny. Her naiveness made it funnier than ever.
老达琳听了笑得不行。但她想不通自己在笑什么。她说得越多，情况越糟。她没法联系到整件事。你看，她说，她以为这和倒垃圾之类的有关。我不记得她当时具体说了什么。不管怎样，这真的很搞笑。她的天真比以往任何时候都更有趣。
I'm going to quit for now. I've got some big holes to drill downstairs. And tonight's Fugitive night. I haven't watched Fugitive for so many months, I don't know whether he's still afoot or horseback. So well, anyway, so much for that. It's really been nice to talk to you.
我先不说了。我得去楼下钻几个大孔了。今晚是《亡命天涯》之夜。我已经好几个月没看《亡命天涯》了，不知道他还在逃亡还是已经骑马了。所以，好吧，就说这么多。和你聊天真是太好了。
And I want to leave you with one really profound statement that the more you drill on these castings, the lighter they get. I want you to be sure if you don't remember anything else that you remember that. So son, we love you. We'll see you.
我想留给你一句非常深刻的话，你在这些铸件上钻得越多，它们就越轻。如果什么都不记得，我一定要你记得这一点。所以儿子，我们爱你。再见。
[MUSIC - "IT'S A MAN'S WORLD" BY JAMES BROWN]
[音乐 - 詹姆斯·布朗的《It's a Man's World》]
Well, Alix Spiegel, on our radio staff, did a few days of detective work and tracked down the Davis family, who mailed this tape to their son in medical school in the late 1960s. And we reached the former medical student, Arthur Davis, Junior, in his home in Indio, California, not far from Palm Springs. He practices family medicine. He actually makes house calls, he said, and has six kids of his own. And he told us that these letters on tape went back and forth between him and his parents for a period of about four years when he was away in California in medical school.
我们电台的工作人员艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔做了几天的调查工作，找到了戴维斯一家，他们在20世纪60年代末把这盘录音带寄给了在医学院读书的儿子。我们联系上了那位前医学生阿瑟·戴维斯二世，他在加州因迪奥的家中，离棕榈泉不远。他是一名家庭医生。他说他甚至会去出诊，而且有六个自己的孩子。他说，这些录音带信件往来于他和父母之间，持续了大约四年，当时他正在加州上医学院。
He said, no, he hadn't heard one since the 1960s. He said, no, he had no idea how one could end up in a thrift store in Chicago. No, he said, his parents were not still alive. His mother died 12 years ago, and his father died 4 years ago.
他说，不，他从60年代起就没听过一盘。他说，不，他根本不知道这东西怎么会流落到芝加哥的旧货店。他说，不，他的父母已经不在人世了。他的母亲12年前去世，父亲4年前去世。
We sent him uncut tapes of everything that was on the tape. And he heard them. And he said that it was fine with him for us to play the tapes on the radio. He said that the tapes captured the dynamics of his family perfectly. The drama of a lot of American families is the emotional distance of the father, the father staying away from the family orbit, the father not being around, the father holding himself apart. And Arthur Davis, Junior says that his father was like a lot of American dads in that way and was, in fact, pretty removed.
我们把录音带上所有内容的完整备份寄给了他。他听了。他说，他完全同意我们在广播里播放这些录音带。他说，录音带完美地捕捉了他家庭的动态。许多美国家庭的戏剧性在于父亲的情感疏离，父亲游离于家庭轨道之外，父亲不在身边，父亲保持距离。阿瑟·戴维斯二世说，他的父亲在这一点上和许多美国父亲一样，事实上，确实相当疏远。
He was reared in a divorced home. And there was a lot of bitterness. And so it was pretty tough for him to even consider getting married. And then when I was born, my mom said that he just broke into tears, thinking that he might have to deal with some of those issues as a parent. He never did really want to be a parent. And she really helped him through that a lot.
他是在单亲家庭长大的。有很多痛苦。所以即使考虑结婚对他来说也相当艰难。后来我出生时，我妈妈说他竟然流下了眼泪，想到他作为一个父亲可能要处理其中的一些问题。他从未真正想成为一名父亲。而她真的帮他克服了很多。
It was very fascinating, Ira. After my mom died, my dad changed tremendously. And he came to live with me, and spent quite a bit of time with my sister and me, and was very connected with us and our children. So that all changed after Mom died.
这非常迷人，艾拉。我母亲去世后，我父亲发生了巨大的变化。他来和我住在一起，花了很多时间和我和我姐姐在一起，与我们和我们的孩子建立了紧密的联系。所以这一切在母亲去世后都改变了。
Arthur Davis, Junior. Coming up, more old tapes, more about fathers in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
阿瑟·戴维斯二世。接下来，会有更多的旧录音带，更多关于父亲的故事，稍后请继续收听来自国际公共广播电台的节目。
Well, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to tackle that theme with radio monologues, original reporting, memoirs, short fiction, anything they can think of. Today's program, Accidental Documentaries. Stories made from old tapes that have been sitting in basements, and attics, and thrift stores for decades. We have arrived at Act Two of our program, Baltimore.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者通过广播独白、原创报道、回忆录、短篇小说等任何他们能想到的方式来探讨这个主题。今天的节目是“意外的纪录片”。这些故事是由几十年来一直存放在地下室、阁楼和旧货店里的旧录音带制作而成的。我们现在进入了节目的第二幕，巴尔的摩。
We'd like to ask you this question, my friend. Do personal problems and worries have you down? Are you disturbed by business problems, marriage problems, or emotional problems? See Mrs. K, reader and adviser. Mrs. K, formerly of Europe, gives you a reading and answers all your questions for just $1. And you'll feel much better. You'll have a much better picture of where you're headed after you've talk with Mrs. K. The telephone number is Saratoga 7-2753, but, of course, no appointment is necessary.
朋友，我们要问你这个问题。你是否因个人的问题和烦恼而感到沮丧？你是否被工作问题、婚姻问题或情感问题所困扰？请找K夫人，她是一位读心者和顾问。曾旅居欧洲的K夫人只需1美元，就能为你解读并回答你所有的问题。你会感觉好多了。与K夫人交谈后，你对自己未来的人生方向会有更清晰的认识。电话号码是萨拉托加7-2753，当然，无需预约。
I'm just going to stop this tape right there. I have three things to say about this tape. Number one, formally of Europe? Number two, of course, no appointment is necessary. She already knows you're coming. And number three, this is my father in 1956, three years before I was born. He's 23 years old.
我要在这里停一下这段录音。关于这段录音，我有三点要说。第一，曾旅居欧洲？第二，当然，无需预约。她早就知道你要来了。第三，这是我父亲在1956年录的，那时我还没出生，还有三年我才出生。他当时才23岁。
And coming up right now, news about a wonderful appliance from Norman R. Mitchell, yes? For the homemakers, as we said before. We're talking about an electric dryer. And my friend, if the lady in your house has her heart set on an electric dryer, here's some big news for you from Norman R. Mitchell. Right now, they are featuring the new 1957 Frigidaire Filtra-matic electric dryer at an unbelievable low price.
接下来，是来自诺曼·R·米切尔关于一款美妙家电的新闻，对吧？正如我们之前所说，这是为家庭主妇准备的。我们谈论的是一台电动干衣机。我的朋友，如果你家里的女主人一心想要一台电动干衣机，诺曼·R·米切尔这里有个好消息要告诉你。现在，他们正在以不可思议的低价推销新款1957年款富及第Filtra-matic电动干衣机。
My father started in radio when he was 19, the same age I was when I started. He began at the college station at the University of Maryland, and, after graduation, got a job spinning records at a commercial station in Baltimore. Then he was drafted. And at the time of this particular recording, my father was actually in the Army, stationed in Virginia. But he wanted a career in radio so badly that every Sunday morning, at the break of dawn, he would leave his wife and his five-month-old baby, my older sister, and drive up to Baltimore to do a four-hour program.
我父亲19岁时就开始从事广播工作，那和我开始入行时一样的年纪。他最初是在马里兰大学的校园电台工作，毕业后，他在巴尔的摩的一家商业电台找到了一份打碟的工作。后来他应征入伍。在录制这段音频时，我父亲实际上正在弗吉尼亚州服兵役。但他太渴望广播事业了，以至于每个周日黎明时分，他都会离开妻子和当时五个月大的婴儿——也就是我姐姐，开车去巴尔的摩主持一个四小时的节目。
For over 18 years, thousands of folks just like yourselves here in town have relied on Norman R. Mitchell appliances for sincerity, service, and substantial savings. Three important must's for a successful business today.
18年多来，成千上万像你们一样的当地人一直信赖诺曼·R·米切尔家电的真诚、服务和实实在在的优惠。这三点是当今成功企业不可或缺的要素。
My dad's paycheck for this four-hour Sunday morning program was $5.88. The most he ever made at a radio job was $90 a week.
我父亲主持这个周日早晨四小时节目的薪水是5.88美元。他在广播工作中赚到的最高薪水是每周90美元。
My friend, how would you like to get 21 beautiful greeting cards absolutely free? Plus details on how easy it is to earn $35 to $50 a week selling Liberty Bell greeting cards?
我的朋友，如果能免费得到21张精美的贺卡，你想要吗？此外，我们还会提供关于如何通过销售自由钟贺卡，轻松赚取每周35到50美元的详细信息。
Hey Dad?
嘿，爸爸？
Yeah.
嗯。
When you were doing radio, what did you like about it? What was the appeal of it for you?
当你做广播的时候，你喜欢它的哪一点？它对你有什么吸引力？
It seemed easy to do. Certain amount of, I guess, notoriety. It's good for your ego. People know who you are. I was a big man on campus at the University of Maryland.
这看起来很容易。我想，还有一定程度的知名度。这对你的虚荣心有好处。人们知道你是谁。我在马里兰大学时可是校园里的风云人物。
You're a good announcer. I didn't really know that. I've been listening to the way that you do the announcements. You're relaxed, and yet, you punch the main points. But you sound completely at ease, and you're convincing. You're doing ads for the hokiest products in the world, and you sound completely like you believe it.
你是个出色的播音员。我以前真不知道。我一直在听你做播报的方式。你很放松，但又能抓住重点。你的声音听起来非常自如，而且很有说服力。你当时在为世界上最土的产品做广告，但听起来你完全相信它们。
Really? What are some of the products? I've forgot about them.
真的吗？有哪些产品？我都忘了。
There's a lot of appliances. And then there's one reader and adviser named Mrs. K.
有很多家电。还有一位叫K夫人的读心者和顾问。
That's right. I'd forgotten about her.
没错。我都快忘了她了。
Formerly of Europe.
曾旅居欧洲。
Just show them to your relatives, friends, neighbors, and the folks you work with, and see how quickly they order. You're actually doing them a favor by saving them money on Christmas cards. And such fine quality cards you've never seen in your life as Liberty Bell.
只需要把它们展示给你的亲戚、朋友、邻居和同事看，看看他们下单的速度有多快。通过帮他们节省购买圣诞贺卡的费用，你实际上是在帮他们的忙。你这辈子都没见过像自由钟这样高质量的贺卡。
A lot of what it's like to be on the radio is just trying to sound relaxed when you're not. You're doing a show. You're not just talking to people. And in some of these tapes, I can actually hear my father struggling to sound relaxed. And these recordings give me this picture of him that I have never had in my life really. He seems so young and innocent. A guy in his 20s, doing this thing that I know so intimately myself, just sitting in front of a microphone trying to sound at ease, trying to sound like this relaxed old pro, not a care in the world.
做广播的很大一部分工作，其实就是当你并不放松时，尽量让自己听起来很放松。你在主持节目，而不仅仅是在和人交谈。在这些录音中，我甚至能听出父亲在努力让自己听起来很放松。这些录音让我看到了一个我从未见过的他。他看起来那么年轻，那么单纯。一个20多岁的小伙子，做着我本人也非常熟悉的事情——就坐在麦克风前，努力让自己听起来很自在，试图装作一个经验丰富的老手，仿佛世间无忧。
Yes, now you can have color in that kitchen of yours and really make it a true showplace for your family and your friends. And make it a lot easier to work in too with color, huh? And you can have this color in your kitchen all at the price of white. And of course, Frigidaire features the new 1957 Frigidaire refrigerators, ranges, washers, and dryers in four decorator colors at absolutely no extra cost to you. You have your choice of pink, yellow, green, or charcoal.
是的，现在你可以让你的厨房拥有色彩，真正成为你家人和朋友眼中的风景。而且，有了色彩，工作起来也会更轻松，对吧？你可以在厨房里拥有这种色彩，而且价格和白色的电器一样。当然，富及第推出了新款1957年富及第冰箱、炉灶、洗衣机和干衣机，有四种装饰色可供选择，且绝对无需额外费用。你可以选择粉色、黄色、绿色或炭灰色。
This is just how long ago this happened. They had not yet invented the idea of renaming the colors of appliances, things like avocado, lemon, eggshell.
这就是事情过去多久了。他们当时还没有发明出为电器颜色重新命名的点子，比如鳄梨色、柠檬色、蛋壳色之类的。
Well, let's get on to that featured top tune of tomorrow, a brand new release, one we think is going to be real big in the coming weeks and months all across the country and right here in Baltimore too. This week, it goes to The Crew Cuts. Listen to their rendition of "Love In A Home."
好了，让我们进入明天的热门金曲推荐，这是一首全新的发布，我们认为它在未来几周和几个月内会火遍全国，当然也包括这里——巴尔的摩。本周，它属于“船员剪影”合唱团。请听他们演绎的《家中的爱》。
Not long after he got out of the Army, my dad decided that radio was no way to make a living. And after a series of jobs, he decided to become a Certified Public Accountant. He was a typical workaholic, suburban dad. Off to the office at 7:00 in the morning. Back at 6:30 for dinner. Exhausted after that, he would sit in his yellow recliner in front of the TV and fall asleep. He started his own business, struggled to establish it, worked lots of nights and weekends. During tax season, from January to April 15, we would barely see him.
退伍后不久，我父亲就断定广播不是长久之计。在换了几份工作后，他决定成为一名注册会计师。他是一个典型的职场狂人、郊区父亲。早上7点去办公室。6点半回家吃晚饭。在那之后精疲力尽的他，会坐在电视前的黄色躺椅上睡着。他创办了自己的公司，努力打拼，牺牲了很多夜晚和周末。在每年一月到四月十五日的报税季，我们几乎见不到他。
What's this?
这是什么？
This.
这个。
Is that a radio?
这是一个收音机吗？
Radio.
收音机。
In our house when I was growing up was an old reel-to-reel tape recorder, a little consumer unit, that my mother and my sisters and I would goof around on from time to time, record us singing or telling stories. And while my mom appears on these tapes a lot, my father does not appear on them once. He simply was not there to be recorded. The only time he's mentioned on all of these tapes is this. I'm going to play this moment to you. My mother is cooing to my older sister, Randi, who's probably-- I don't know-- a year old, a year and a half old.
在我成长的过程中，我们家里有一台老式的卷盘式录音机，那是一台小型消费级设备。我和妈妈、姐姐们偶尔会用它玩耍，录下我们唱歌或讲故事的声音。虽然我妈妈在这些磁带里出现过很多次，但我父亲一次都没出现过。他根本没在那儿被录下来。在所有这些磁带中，唯一提到他的时刻就是这个。我把这个片段放给你听。我妈妈正在对大姐兰迪轻声细语，兰迪当时可能……我不知道……一岁半左右。
Where's Barry?
巴里在哪儿？
Barry's my dad.
巴里是我爸爸。
Where's Barry, Randi? Daddy? Where's daddy? Did daddy go bye-bye?
巴里在哪儿，兰迪？爸爸呢？爸爸去哪儿了？爸爸是不是出门了？
Go bye-bye.
出门了。
Did he go outside?
他去外面了吗？
Go bye-bye.
出门了。
In the car?
在车里吗？
Car. Bye-bye.
车里。拜拜。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
These days, my dad explains his decision to leave radio and become an accountant this way.
如今，我父亲这样解释他当年离开广播界转行做会计的决定。
By that time, I had realized that radio was not for me. What happened would be a new program director would come in. And if you weren't the apple of that guy's eye, then you were out of a job, and you gotta go start looking for a job again. Even though that never happened to me, I could see it happening to other people. And I wanted to be in control of my own destiny, and I decided that it wasn't going to work out. Radio was not going to work out.
到那时候，我已经意识到广播不适合我。通常发生的情况是，新来的节目总监上任。如果你不是那个人的心腹，那你就会丢掉工作，然后不得不重新开始找工作。尽管这种情况从未发生在我身上，但我能看到它发生在别人身上。我想要掌控自己的命运，我决定这条路行不通。广播事业是行不通的。
And that was 1959?
那是1959年吗？
Yeah.
对。
The year I was born?
我出生的那一年？
Right.
没错。
Are those two things related?
这两件事有关联吗？
Not at all.
完全没有。
It sounds like they are.
听起来好像有关联。
No, they're not. No, they're not.
不，没有。真的没有。
Well, all the stars are on record, and all the records star on the Sunday Morning Carousel. Coming up for you right now, our featured top tune of the day. Number one in the record stores we visited this week in Baltimore. And judging by your cards and letters here at WIN, it ranks very high. The Prince of Wales himself, one Johnnie Ray, with "Just Walkin' in the Rain."
好了，所有的明星都留下了录音，而所有的唱片都在“周日早晨旋转木马”节目中大放异彩。现在为你带来我们本周推荐的金曲。这是我们在巴尔的摩唱片店走访发现的第一名。从WIN电台收到的听众来信来看，它排名非常高。威尔士亲王本人，约翰尼·雷，带来《雨中漫步》。
Now the way a story like this usually ends is that I reveal that this is why I'm in radio, to make good on my father's legacy, to live the dream that he never got to live. But I have to say, the fact is, I never knew him as a radio deejay. I did not know that he had ever done radio the entire time I grew up. It was never discussed. The recordings of him doing this stuff were packed away in the basement. Nobody talked about it. I never thought of him as somebody who did anything but certified public accounting. If my mom ever mentioned this, I do not remember it.
现在，这种故事通常的结局是，我会透露这就是我进入广播界的原因，为了实现父亲未竟的梦想，继承他的遗产。但我必须说，事实是，我从未见过他作为广播DJ的样子。在我成长的过程中，我根本不知道他曾做过广播。这件事从未被讨论过。他录制这些节目的磁带被打包放在地下室里。没人谈论它。我从没想过他除了做注册会计师以外还会做别的事。如果我妈提到过，我也记不得了。
And I certainly didn't grow up with any special feeling about radio. I could care less about radio. Like most Americans, my medium of choice was television. I got my first job with National Public Radio in Washington when I was 19 years old. And at that point, I simply wanted a job in the media. I was a freshman in college. If an ad agency had hired me that summer, right now, I would probably be doing Bud Light commercials. I can just see the whole thing laying out that way.
而且我成长过程中肯定没有对广播有什么特别的情结。我一点也不在乎广播。像大多数美国人一样，我选择的媒介是电视。我在19岁那年获得了华盛顿国家公共广播电台的第一份工作。当时，我只是想在媒体界找份工作。那时我还是个大一新生。如果那年夏天一家广告代理公司雇了我，现在我可能正在拍百威淡啤的广告。我完全能想象出那会是怎样的一番景象。
And in 1978, when I started working at NPR, my parents absolutely did not want me to do it. It wasn't even a judgment call. They were completely against it for the next, I want to say, 10 years, maybe it was 15 years really. They simply saw it the way most parents would. They saw it as impractical. They worried that I would never make any decent money, never be able to support a family, essentially, the reasons that my father quit radio.
而在1978年，当我开始在NPR工作时，我父母绝对不希望我这样做。这甚至不是评价的问题。在接下来的10年，或许是15年里，他们完全反对。他们就像大多数父母一样看待这份工作。他们觉得这不切实际。他们担心我永远赚不到像样的钱，永远无法养家糊口，这本质上就是我父亲放弃广播的原因。
When I first dug out these tapes of my father, about a year ago, I asked my dad if he ever wished he could still do radio. And he was completely unenthusiastic about the idea. In all my life, I had only seen his desire to be on the radio once. And this was actually a couple years ago. I was filling in as the guest host of Talk of the Nation, this daily call-in show NPR does out of Washington. I was doing that for half a year. And my father had never seen me host a radio show.
大约一年前，当我第一次翻出我父亲的这些旧磁带时，我问他是否还想做广播。他对这个想法完全不感兴趣。在我的一生中，我只看到过他一次流露出想做广播的愿望。那其实是几年前的事。当时我正在担任NPR华盛顿节目《国家对话》的代班主持，我做了半年。而我父亲从未看过我主持广播节目。
And he and my mom drove down to Washington from Baltimore to watch me do the show. And before the show, he asked me if he could read the news. And at first, I thought he was joking. And I don't remember exactly what I said, but I joked something back at him. And then later, as we got closer to going on the air, he asked again that he would like to read the newscast, the NPR newscast at the top of the hour, at the beginning of the show. And I realized he was serious. And I had to explain to him that I didn't have any authority over that, that the NPR newscasters, they wrote their own news, and they delivered it themselves.
他和妈妈特地从巴尔的摩开车到华盛顿看我做节目。节目开始前，他问我他能不能播报新闻。起初，我以为他在开玩笑。我不记得我具体说了什么，我跟他开了个玩笑。后来，随着我们要上直播了，他又问了一次，说他想播报新闻，就是节目开始时在整点播报的NPR新闻。我意识到他是认真的。我不得不向他解释我没有那样的权限，因为NPR的新闻主播都是自己写稿、自己播报的。
Since then I've had him on our show a few times, on this show, including as an announcer, co-hosting a Father's Day show. He's coming around, I think. Lately, he's started saying that maybe I did not make such a mistake going into radio, that it seemed to be working out OK, which I'm glad for. I think one of the hardest things for any parent is to have one set of expectations for their children, and then be forced by their children to change them. That's really hard. I can't imagine what it would be like to see your kid doing something that you, yourself, decided wasn't worth doing.
从那以后，我让他上过我们节目几次，包括让他当播音员，共同主持父亲节特辑。我想，他正在慢慢接受。最近，他开始说，也许我投身广播界并没有选错，事情似乎进行得很顺利，对此我感到很高兴。我认为对任何父母来说，最困难的事情之一，就是为孩子设定一套期望，然后被迫接受孩子改变这些期望。这真的很难。我无法想象，看到自己的孩子去做你本人认为不值得做的事情，会是什么样的感觉。
And time for us to go out on a limb and predict big things for a new record. Our featured top tune of tomorrow. Here's a guy we feel pretty safe in predicting big things for. His name is Nat King Cole. Our featured top tune of tomorrow, "My Personal Possession."
现在是时候让我们大胆预测一下一张新唱片了。明天的热门金曲推荐。这是一个我们很有把握预测会大火的人。他的名字叫纳特·金·科尔。我们明天推荐的这首歌是《我的个人财产》。
[MUSIC - "MY PERSONAL POSSESSION" BY NAT KING COLE]
［音乐 - 纳特·金·科尔的《我的个人财产》］
Act Three, Chicago. Nora Moreno now joins us with some records, and tapes, and a story.
第三幕，芝加哥。诺拉·莫雷诺现在带来了唱片、录音带和一个故事。
This is an old 45. It's my father. He was a pioneer in Spanish-language broadcasting here in Chicago, a radio announcer in the 1950s and '60s. My dad's not playing the guitar or singing on this record. He's reciting poetry. This is what he sounded like when I was little.
这是一张旧的45转唱片。这是我父亲。他是芝加哥西班牙语广播界的先驱，也是上世纪五六十年代的广播播音员。我父亲在这张唱片里没有弹吉他或唱歌。他在朗诵诗歌。这就是我小时候他听起来的样子。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
［说西班牙语］
"I knew love."
“我曾懂得爱。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
［说西班牙语］
"It was very beautiful."
“它曾是那么美丽。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
［说西班牙语］
"But in me--"
“但在我心中——”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
［说西班牙语］
"In me, it was fleeting and a traitor."
“在我心中，它转瞬即逝，像个叛徒。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
［说西班牙语］
"It blemished what was glorious. But it was great because it was the first love."
“它玷污了那些辉煌。但它依然伟大，因为那是初恋。”
It was hearing my dad recite poems like this that made my mother fall in love with him. It was a poem called "El Brindis del Bohemio" about Bohemians toasting in the New Year that did her in.
正是听到我父亲朗诵这样的诗句，让我母亲爱上了他。那首叫做《波西米亚人的祝酒辞》的诗，讲的是波西米亚人在新年聚会上举杯，正是这首诗打动了她。
"El Brindis del Bohemio." Beautiful.
“《波西米亚人的祝酒辞》。太美了。”
Describe it. What does it say?
描述一下它。它说了什么？
Well, this poem talks about women, the mother, the mistress, the girlfriend.
嗯，这首诗谈论的是女性，母亲、情妇和女朋友。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
［说西班牙语］
There was a soldier. There was a Bohemio. And there was another guy. And they were doing this toast. The best part was when this Bohemio-- the toast is for the mother, the one who carry him nine month, the one who cry with him and took care of him when he was a baby.
有一个士兵，有一个波西米亚人，还有另外一个人。他们正在举杯祝酒。最精彩的部分是当这个波西米亚人——这次祝酒是献给母亲的，那个怀胎九月生下他，那个为他哭泣，在他还是婴儿时照顾他的女人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
［说西班牙语］
I know what my mother was thinking when she heard this. Any man who can get so worked up about his mother had to be a special man. So she called the radio station. They talked on the telephone, went out, and, three months later, they were married.
我知道我母亲听到这些时在想什么。任何一个能为母亲如此动情的男人，一定是个特别的男人。于是她给电台打了电话。他们在电话里交谈，见了面，三个月后，他们结婚了。
Now falling in love with the voice on the radio may sound a bit extreme, but consider this. My mother was 16, in Chicago for only a few months after having lived in Puerto Rico. It was her first time in the States. She barely spoke English and mostly stayed at home.
现在，爱上广播里的声音听起来可能有点极端，但考虑到这一点：我母亲当时才16岁，在波多黎各生活过之后，来到芝加哥才几个月。这是她第一次来美国。她几乎不会说英语，大部分时间都待在家里。
It was like being in a cage after living on an island with the sun shining and sleeping with the doors open and windows. And when I came here and went to that apartment, I feel like I was dead to life. I used to cry every night.
在岛上生活时阳光明媚，睡觉时门窗大开，到了这儿就像被关进笼子里一样。当我来到这儿并走进那个公寓时，我觉得自己就像行尸走肉。我几乎每晚都哭。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
［说西班牙语］
I'm not even going to bother translating this one. Let's just say it's very romantic about the perfection of a woman's eyes. And this man, the one you're hearing, I never knew him. Sure, I heard stories about his radio shows, how he would produce talent shows, and have live performances, and bring in crowds from all over the city. People would come to be part of live radio. Women wanted to hear him and his poetry.
我甚至懒得翻译这一段。只能说，这关于女性双眸的完美，极其浪漫。而这个男人，你听到的这个人，我却从未真正了解过。当然，我听过关于他广播节目的故事，关于他如何制作选秀节目，如何举办现场演出，并从城市各地吸引人群。人们来到现场参与广播节目。女人们想听他的声音和他的诗歌。
But by the time I was old enough to hear him on the radio, he was reading the news and not poetry. And what I remember were the fights between them, my mother and father, about how he was never home, always late, too busy for us. His life on the radio was all consuming. The very thing that brought my parents together drove them apart. And I had fights with him too.
但等我长大到能听懂他广播的时候，他已经只在读新闻，而不读诗歌了。我记得的是父母之间的争吵，关于他为什么从不回家，总是迟到，为我们忙得不可开交。他的广播生涯消耗了一切。正是那个促成我父母结合的东西，最终拆散了他们。我和他之间也有过争吵。
Once when I was 16, my dad came home after being away for a few days. And I asked him what he was working on that kept him away so much. It wasn't as if he was out of town. He just didn't come home. Well, he didn't appreciate it, got very indigent, and he beat me.
16岁那年，我父亲在外地待了几天回到家。我问他一直在忙什么，以至于要离家那么久。他并不是出差，只是不回家而已。他对此很不高兴，变得非常气愤，还打了我。
Partly, he was defensive because he was seeing another woman. And partly, it was because of this culture clash. I was talking to him like an American girl, but he was born in Mexico. And in Spanish families, you never questioned your father. You never questioned your dad. In his mind, there was nothing more disrespectful than a child questioning the authority of her father.
一部分原因是他当时有了外遇，所以心虚；另一部分原因是文化冲突。我用美国女孩的方式跟他说话，但他是在墨西哥出生的。在西班牙裔家庭里，你永远不能质疑父亲，不能质疑爸爸。在他看来，没有什么比孩子质疑父亲的权威更不孝的了。
When my mother found out about the other woman, she couldn't believe it and didn't. He would tell her in that same beautiful voice that he still loved her. He persuaded her that she was imagining things, convinced her that there was no one else and could never be anyone else but her, all in that voice, that romantic, seductive, tempting voice that she had heard on the radio. Finally, after another one of their many fights, after months of continuous abuse, my mother took a gun and shot my father in the mouth.
当母亲发现他有外遇时，她简直不敢相信，也不愿相信。他用那同样美妙的声音告诉她，他依然爱她。他用那声音说服了她，让她以为自己是在胡思乱想，让她确信除了她没有别人，也不可能有别人。那声音正是母亲曾在广播里听到的，那种浪漫、诱人、迷人的声音。最终，在他们无数次争吵中的又一次爆发后，在经历了数月持续不断的虐待后，我母亲拿起一把枪，朝我父亲的嘴里开了一枪。
My dad survived the gunshot. And when the police came, he lied to them about what had happened, so they wouldn't take my mother to jail. He told them that he was teaching her to shoot when the gun went off. The cops didn't believe him, but he didn't want to press charges, and basically, there was nothing they could do. The strange thing is that, for a while, that whole experience brought them closer together. For a while.
我父亲在枪击中幸存了下来。警察赶到时，他谎称发生了意外，这样他们就不会把我母亲带走坐牢。他告诉警察，当时他正在教她射击，枪不小心走火了。警察并不相信他，但他不愿提出指控，基本上，他们也无能为力。奇怪的是，在那之后的一段时间里，这段经历反而让他们变得亲近了一些。只是在那一段时间里。
A couple of years ago, I decided to meet my father in Mexico. We were going to celebrate Father's Day together. I don't really know why we picked Father's Day. We both understood that being a father wasn't something he did very well. And when I think about it now, I can't remember a time in my life when I recognized that day. The point is that he didn't show up.
几年前，我决定去墨西哥见我父亲。我们打算一起庆祝父亲节。我真的不知道为什么我们选了父亲节。我们俩都心知肚明，他并不是个称职的父亲。现在回想起来，我记不起人生中哪一次真正重视过那个日子。重点是，他那天没出现。
It makes me sad because what I ended up doing was so much fun, and I knew he would have enjoyed himself too. I went to visit my uncle and cousins in Mexico City. We told stories, recited poetry, talked a lot about my dad. My cousin even brought out his guitar and tried to recite some of the poems my dad used to read. It was typical for my dad not to show up to things that included the family. Now that he's not really a part of it, it seems normal.
这让我很难过，因为我最终在那儿玩得很开心，我知道他其实也会喜欢的。我去墨西哥城探望了叔叔和堂兄妹们。我们讲故事，朗诵诗歌，谈论了很多关于我爸爸的事。我堂兄甚至拿出吉他，试着朗诵我爸爸过去常读的一些诗。对我爸爸来说，缺席涉及家人的聚会是很典型的行为。现在他已经不怎么参与家庭生活了，这反而显得很正常。
My parents are divorced. My dad is in Texas, lonely and broke, dying of cancer. He's been out of radio for almost 20 years. When I talked to him on Monday and asked him about his poems, he couldn't remember the last time he had written one.
我父母离婚了。我爸爸在得克萨斯州，孤独而破产，正饱受癌症折磨。他已经离开广播界快20年了。周一我跟他通话问起他的诗时，他已经记不起上一次写诗是什么时候了。
I have a picture of my dad on a stage with the backdrop of a Spanish dancer and a big band surrounding him. There's a woman sharing the stage with him. She is elegant and stunning. She has this long, flowing evening dress. This woman is not my mother, but she captures my father. He's bowing at the waist. She holds out a hand to him, and he clasps it with both of his and kisses it, gazing up into her eyes with complete romantic concentration. His attention is for her alone.
我有一张照片，照片上我爸爸站在舞台上，背景是跳西班牙舞的人和一支大型乐队。有一个女人和他同台。她优雅动人，穿着一件长长的飘逸晚礼服。那个女人不是我母亲，但她迷住了我父亲。他深深地鞠着躬。她向他伸出一只手，他用双手握住，亲吻着它，深情地凝望着她的眼睛，神情极其浪漫专注。他眼里只有她。
Nora Moreno works in philanthropy at the Boeing Company in Chicago.
诺拉·莫雷诺在芝加哥波音公司从事慈善工作。
Nora, to end our story about your dad and you, you asked us especially to get this one particular song called "El  Rey."
诺拉，为了结束我们关于你父亲和你的故事，你特意要求我们选播这首名叫《国王》的歌。
The king.
《国王》。
Explain the significance of this song.
解释一下这首歌的意义吧。
Well, it's my dad's favorite song. And he sort of took it on as a theme for his life.
嗯，这是我爸爸最喜欢的歌。他把它当作了自己的人生主题曲。
Can you tell us why this would be his favorite song?
能告诉我们为什么这是他最喜欢的歌吗？
Well, it talks about a man who has no place. And regardless of where he finds himself, he continues to be the king.
嗯，它讲述了一个无处容身的男人的故事。无论他身处何方，他始终都是国王。
[MUSIC - "EL REY"]
[音乐 - 《国王》]
"I know very well that I am outside, but the day that I die, I know you will have to cry."
“我很清楚自己是个局外人，但当我死去的那一天，我知道你们不得不为我哭泣。”
"Cry, cry, cry," they're singing.
“哭吧，哭吧，哭吧”，他们在唱着。
Yeah. "You will say that you never loved me, but you will be very sad. And you'll be that way forever. With money or without money, I always do what I want. And my word is the law. I have no throne, or queen, or anyone who understands me, but I continue to be the king."
是的。“你会说你从未爱过我，但你会非常难过。你会永远那样。无论有没有钱，我总是做我想做的事。我的话就是法则。我没有王位，没有王后，也没有人能理解我，但我始终是国王。”
Have you actually heard him sing this song?
你真的听他唱过这首歌吗？
Oh, yes. He sang this at parties, family gatherings, in the morning. He sang this all the time.
哦，是的。他在派对上、家庭聚会上，甚至在早晨都唱。他一直都在唱。
What's so beautiful about it is the guy in the song is clearly-- he knows he's not really the king. He knows he's not--
最美妙的地方在于，歌里的那个人显然——他知道自己并不是真正的国王。他知道他不是——
Well, actually, Ira, that's not really true. I think that what's truer is that he really thinks he's king.
嗯，其实，艾拉，那并不是真的。我认为更真实的情况是，他真的认为自己是国王。
No.
不。
Yes. It was a tribute to the way he lived his life. His way. You know, Frank Sinatra?
是的。这是对他一生处世之道的一种致敬。他行事的方式。你知道弗兰克·辛纳屈吗？
It's funny you say that. I was just about to say, this is the Spanish "My Way."
你这么说真有趣。我正想说，这就是西班牙语版的《我行我素》。
"El Rey."
《国王》。
Well, thank you Nora Moreno. Our program produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Nancy Updike, Peter Clowney, and Dolores Wilber. Today's show was first broadcast in 1996, one of the first episodes of our program. Contributing editors for this show, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Paul Tough, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Music help from Mr. John Connors.
好的，谢谢诺拉·莫雷诺。今天的节目由爱丽克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人制作，参与制作的还有南希·厄普代克、彼得·克劳尼和多洛雷斯·威尔伯。今天的节目首播于1996年，是我们节目的早期剧集之一。本节目的特约编辑是杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、保罗·塔夫和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。音乐协助来自约翰·康纳斯先生。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can get our free weekly podcast or listen to old programs online. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站是 www.thisamericanlife.org，你可以在那里获取我们免费的每周播客或在线收听往期节目。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
WBEZ电台对我们节目的管理监制是托里·马拉蒂亚先生。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，带给你更多《美国生活》的故事。
Well, anyway, so much for that. It's really been nice to talk to you. And I want to leave you with one really profound statement that the more you drill in these castings, the lighter they get. I want you to be sure if you don't remember anything else that you remember that.
好吧，无论如何，就到此为止吧。和你聊天真的很愉快。我想留给你一句非常深刻的话：你在这些铸件上钻孔钻得越多，它们就越轻。我希望如果你记不住别的事，一定要记住这一点。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台（PRI）。